the great thing about street food is
anything goes the Only Rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos makes them Mexican and
Japanese flavors into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off get that pan really nice and
hot these are sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
I'll add flavor
salt and pepper
a couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan nice and hot
hold of the stake
and lay it in always lay away
to the Pano a little shake and it stops
the steak from sticking we're looking
for color
that it sticks it's gonna burn
while the steaks are cooking I can go
with my super quick marinade now
two tablespoons of
me soup paste that's a fermented soybean
that gives a really nice sort of Rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar a couple tablespoons
rice wine that gives it a really nice
fengary kick a couple of tablespoons of
olive oil
salt and pepper
I'm looking for a nice sort of thick
Rich marinade
mayonnaise done it's time to turn the
steaks
I saw the pan
into the other steaks a little based all
we're doing every time is just adding
more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really melt all
that fat down
off of the gas
take them out just take your knife
see all that fat there just slice that
off
I don't want any of that
now in
to the marinade
[Music]
useful
tacos are one of Mexico's most popular
Street Foods they've been made from beef
pork chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now I want something sort of pickly
cabbage these are Chinese cabbages slice
it in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
I'm gonna slice that into quarters and
then just shred it and take your time
think of cabbage here and you think of
sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but attacker you want freshness
a little season of chili flakes
they sort of discreetly give it a little
bit of heat
a little touch of rice wine vinegar if
you haven't got that fresh lemon juice
small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix
now I need something to sort of bring it
together we take some Wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
I'm going to mix that
a couple of tablespoons of mayonnaise
give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them actually place it
on
the guest room
use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan from there
I'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin literally 30 seconds
as it cools down the great thing about
serving tacos is people can fill them
themselves just the way they want them
cabbage just squeeze out let marinade
nice rustic Little Mountain
mayonnaise
on
wait to see how soft and delicious and
almost sort of melting in the mouth
texture we've got on this amazing
sirloin so I've got that really nice
see you around the outside
just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my crispy shell back of
the spoon with the Wasabi mayonnaise
inside taco
just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my attacker with three or
four slices
touch more
am I spicy
Maya
that is how I'd make
the perfect attacker
[Music]
sponge with fresh ginger bacon is part
chemistry part imagination but you've
got to rely on the rules for great
results it's the only time you'll see me
reaching for the scales
first off eggs sugar butter and when I
say weigh out the ingredients it does
literally mean way out to the final Gram
175. now 175 grams
sugar that's 350 grams in total cream
the butter and the sugar
let's get a delicious light sponge start
carefully on slow speed
[Music]
only speed up as the butter and sugar
really start to cream together
keep that really nice and light you can
see how it's changed color so important
at the beginning
eggs in
give them a little whisk
adding one egg at a time stops the mix
from separating second again
third one in
[Music]
that's what we're looking for a really
nice sort of light aerated texture
now I'm gonna flavor the sponge
a little teaspoon of vanilla extract
like perfumes the mix one teaspoon of
baking powder that gives lightness 175
grams of flour and we're going to sieve
it a to get rid of any lumps and B to
keep it really nice and fine
175 We're not gonna beat that out we're
just gonna lightly fold that in now what
I'm looking for is a really nice loose
dough that's looking a little bit too
firm so just a little splash of milk a
couple of tablespoons that relaxes the
mixture down
helps create that nice almost dropping
consistency
that's what I want
see how it's starting to drop
take a non-stick loose bottom cake tin
greasy with butter then coat it with
flour to avoid the sponge sticking
give the handle a shake
getting all the rim
now just get the back of the spatula
make sure you've got no Peaks on my
sponge
to make sure the sponge bakes nice and
evenly tap the tin a few times to knock
out any air pockets that might have
formed in the mixture
now into the oven bake for 30 to 35
minutes at 180 degrees
as that's cooking prepare the ginger
cream for the center 300 mL of cream
give that a nice whisk
whisking cream by hand gives you so much
more control and it's so easy to over
whip cream I want that nice light Ginger
cream in the center I don't want it
grainy nothing worse when cream starts
to separate
now let's get into that three-quarter
stage little stiff peaks
stop that for two minutes fresh ginger
now got a really nice large slice of
Ginger it's that's incredible
it's so fragrant Ginger is like sort of
peeling a potato
to take all those little dark spots now
get your grater
you haven't got a grater you can chop
the ginger really finely
I've got almost like a puree of Ginger
going through but the juice as well take
a knife
just scrape all that
taste
it's incredible
it's fragrant it's not sweet it's got a
really nice taste set that in the fridge
foreign
smells incredible
run a knife around the outside to ensure
the cake doesn't stick to the tin before
turning it out
no get your hands under push up
and out
why your cake cools I'm gonna do like a
really nice sweet chocolate coating pour
300 mL of double cream into a saucepan
add two tablespoons of golden syrup to
make the top nice and glossy then whisk
chop this up really thinly so as it
melts quickly
50 grams of butter that's going to give
the chocolate a really nice shine
boil your cream
and mix it in
give that a really good stir as a
chocolate the butter melts it thickens
look how shiny that is
so nice to finish with something sweet
on top
ping done time to build your sponge cake
look at the halfway mark there
just gently slice
and really take your time all the way
through
lift
that's delicious
a nice big dollop in the middle it'll be
stingy don't be tight with a cream
another dollop on top spread that
very carefully
lift the lid and just sit there on top
that's why I start off with a little
extra cream in there so I want to squash
it down the cream just pushes out to the
side
I'm not finished
poor the luxurious chocolate topping
over the sponge
be generous and make sure the cake is
coated thoroughly to give it a gorgeous
finish get the bottom of the ladle and
spread
whoa
one more
[Music]
you'll know when to say stop and
something looks that delicious
I just want to dive in there
[Music]
[Music]
foreign